About a year ago, I released a video called
“The Problem with Budget Cards”. To this day,
that particular video is my longest video and also
my second best performing video in terms of views.
It’s also wildly unpopular compared to literally
everything else I’ve released. The like to dislike
proportion is an abysmal 77%—for context, my
second lowest is around 95%—and a brief look
at the comments section indicates that a lot of
people take issue with various things contained
within the video. I’ve asked myself a number of
times if I should do something with that video—is
the video truly enough of a departure from the
quality of the rest of my work to warrant some
sort of action, a note in the description or a
pinned comment saying that I, enlightened future
Alex, disavow the contents of the video? And up
until now, I would always come to the conclusion
that the answer is no. My running narrative to
myself has been that it’s a largely fine video,
and that the reason people reacted the way they
did comes down to some poor wording here and
there along with my choice to frontload the most
controversial argument in the video. I figure
this was likely amplified by an especially saucy
thumbnail, along with slow pacing and the droning,
sluggish delivery that characterized my
first three videos. However, I haven’t
really put much thought into the arguments
themselves, and now that a year has passed,
I want to do just that. I am here revisiting that
video, along with its central question—“Are cheap,
powerful cards a problem?” Was I onto something,
or flat out wrong, or somewhere in between?
In order to answer that, I’m going to first
summarize what that video is saying and you
can skip three minutes ahead if you’re already
familiar with the contents of that video.
[clears throat]
Sol Ring is a powerful mana artifact
printed very early in Magic’s history.
It was banned in Legacy and restricted
in Vintage, leading to it commanding a
moderate-but affordable price for players in
the lightly played casual format of commander,
which was slowly gaining steam during the 2000s.
Due to some players considering it a staple,
it ended up being printed in all 5 decks in
the first commander set in 2011. However,
it being a staple is a flawed argument for
reprinting it, because the card was only a
staple due to its affordable price, itself a
result of it not being legal in a large format.
Printing a set for commander would naturally
grow the format, grow the demand for Sol Ring,
and without a reprint the card’s price would be
pushed in line with similar fast mana cards such
as Manacrypt, rendering it likewise a tool for
the power-gamers. I believe the format would be
better if things had played out this way. Some
have argued it should be banned, but that ship
has sailed given the number of reprints it
has seen. However, Sol Ring still poses an
interesting question—what is the effect of cards
with wildly mismatched price and power level?
For one, they warp how players look at other
cards, and this affects how many of a given
type of card players will run. Some players might
decide how many cards of a type to run ahead of
time, but most won’t. Instead, players will add
the best options within their budget, and then a
lot of them will notice the rapidly worsening
power-to-money ratio and stop adding them at a
certain point, even if running more of that type
of card would be better for their deck. With
vegetables like interaction and ramp, it’s easy
to distinguish better options vs worse options,
but when you get to fuzzier, more synergistic
cards it’s more difficult to distinguish card
quality because analyzing them often requires
thinking about a variety of other cards and
different situations. This leads to players adding
a handful of the most powerful vegetable staples,
and then overloading on synergistic cards, leading
to decks that are crammed with win-more cards but
lack a lot of the basic building blocks that
lead to a deck performing well consistently.
In addition to cards that pack a high power
level compared to their price, a related type
of card that can cause problems is expensive
staples that are already in one’s collection,
and which are thus free to add. As an example,
in my mid-power Meria Voltron deck I initially
added Sword of Forge and Frontier, but ended
up cutting it as it felt out of place. It
pumped up the deck’s power level, but without
solving any of the deck’s existing weaknesses,
making the deck less well-rounded overall. As
another example, there are a lot of very powerful
graveyard synergies out there, but the game is
also filled with extremely powerful silver-bullet
graveyard hate. This means that upgrading
a mid-power graveyard deck can backfire,
putting it in competition with decks that will
likely be running cards with the capability to
totally dismantle an unprepared graveyard
deck, and leading to a less consistent
play experience. As another example, choosing to
run infinite combos or other powerful strategies
will draw attacks and interaction from opponents
who are in the know, and this can be a problem
if a player isn’t prepared to deal with this
hate. If your deck has a wide range of power
levels in its potential plays, opponents will
often be wary and default to attacking you,
even if the average power level of your deck
is lower than that of some opposing decks.
Conclusion. Sol Ring is upsettingly powerful but
isn’t going to get banned. You should figure out
the correct number of things you need in
a particular category ahead of time, and
avoid loading up too hard on synergistic win-more
stuff. Sometimes the theoretically most powerful
option out there won’t be the most powerful option
for your deck, and sometimes the most powerful
option for your deck won’t be the best idea for
the type of games you want to play. I don’t run
Torment of Hailfire in my turbo-ramping Glissa
deck because I don’t want my opponents to equate
me having a lot of lands with an immediate game
loss. Queue time machine gag, the video is over.
Okay, that is The Problem with Budget Cards,
condensed down into a pithy three minute
summary. With a year of additional
experience in writing, video making,
and playing commander, what do I think about this
video’s arguments? Well, past the four minute
introduction they’re mostly fine, if a little
unfocused. The second section of the video,
where I talk about the effect of other cards
being framed negatively by cheap powerful cards,
I maybe overstate the social dynamics at play
a little bit, as I had the tendency to do in
some of my earlier videos. However, a lot of my
theorizing here does line up with observations
I’ve had playing commander and looking at
decklists—people do tend to overrate synergistic,
escalation-type cards and underrate some of the
more generic vegetables of the world. Players are
clearly better at distinguishing power levels of
simpler cards as compared to more complex ones,
and this affects what their decks look like. Now,
this point shouldn’t take 7 minutes to make and I
don’t think this section is written as well as it
could be, but the point itself is basically fine.
The third section of the video is what I would
consider to be the core of this video, and it’s
basically a collection of somewhat-related
arguments branching off from the concept
of cards in a deck having diverse power levels.
All of these arguments are individually pretty
good IMHO, and you’ll recognize elements of them
repackaged into later videos I’ve made. Choosing
not to put powerful staples into mid-power decks
is something that I basically made an entire
video about, and I’ve likewise talked about the
problem with adding random infinite combos to a
deck. Deck consistency is also a subject I’ve
talked about numerous times in the past year,
and it’s a core pillar of this section of
the video. Even when I briefly jump back
into talking about Sol Ring near the conclusion
of the video, it’s at this point decently framed,
and I think the argument I make in this section
about the card is a solid one. Having variable
power levels of the cards in your deck can lead to
some unintended problems, and while this isn’t a
blistering indictment of Sol Ring in particular,
it at least makes sense how Sol Ring might fit
into this sort of argumentative framework.
The conclusion to the video basically just
restates a lot of the points in the previous
two sections, and seeing how I’m okay with
most of these points individually, it’s likewise
fine. I don’t think the video does a great job
of connecting the various points within it, but
all of them at least follow to some degree from
the core premise of the video, even if that
premise is made a little murky at times.
With the later parts out of the way, let’s get to
the introduction. The four minute intro is easily
the most controversial part of the video, and
probably the part that ended up causing the lion’s
share of the negative reaction the video received.
So, how do I feel about those arguments now? Well,
the rhetoric is pretty bad—I didn’t argue the
points well. Above all else this is a structure
issue—I simply don’t really articulate what my
problem with Sol Ring is in this section. Why is
it a problem for an extremely powerful card
to exist among much weaker cards in a large
portion of EDH decks? I cover that territory in a
roundabout way later in the video, but that’s not
good enough for a 22 minute YouTube video. Like
sure, if somebody watches the entire video and
evaluates it cohesively they might have a decent
chance of catching on to what I’m going for,
but look at this goddamn graph—less than half
of people are still watching when I get to the
part of the video where I start to justify my
Sol Ring slander. Now, it’s not objectively
bad argumentation to lead with a controversial
claim to draw people in and give them a point of
focus—that can be kinda cool actually—but this
video isn’t set up for that sort of rhetorical
style. It makes a bold argument—that Sol Ring
shouldn’t have been reprinted—with little support
or fanfare, and not much of a framing device with
which to guide the audience to the justifying
points. This is exacerbated by the slow pacing
and bloated runtime of the second section of the
video, as it likely burns off any sort of tension
or momentum that a controversial argument might
garner. This structuring obviously isn’t good for
the reality of people watching YouTube videos,
and it’s weak even for the people who fully
watched the video and charitably interpreted
its contents, as many commenters did. The points
about Sol Ring simply aren’t structured in a good
way to persuade people who don’t already
agree with my conclusions on some level,
and the fact that Sol Ring was then
the framing device for the rest of
the video predictably caused additional
problems in maintaining a cohesive focus.
So that’s it, right? Future enlightened Snail
has decreed that the intro to The Problem with
Budget Cards is bad. Well, no. I mean it’s
not good, let’s be plenty clear about that,
but my views haven’t really changed on the points
I was trying to make. I don’t think Sol Ring
should have been reprinted in commander sets, and
that’s because I don’t think fast mana belongs in
casual commander. I don’t have some crazy essay
worth of stuff to say in defense of that opinion,
I just don’t like what explosive starts do
to the tempo of games. This is the argument I
should have led with in that video if I even
wanted to talk about Sol Ring, because it’s
extremely simple and impossible to misinterpret
for somebody who isn’t fully dedicated to the
task of misinterpreting it. If you disagree that
fast mana doesn’t belong in casual commander,
that's fine—there are valid reasons to disagree
with my thinking here, and I’m not here to change
your mind on that today. I do, however, want to
elaborate a little on why I think not printing
Sol Ring in commander sets would aid in the goal
of keeping fast mana out of casual commander,
because while I think a lot of people can
follow the chain of logic without me explaining,
it’s not entirely trivial. To start with, Sol
Ring is fast mana—a term which generally refers
to cards that are mana positive. Rituals can be
a bit of a grey zone—I generally include them if
they cost no mana—but any repeatably-tapping mana
rock that is mana positive the turn it’s played
is indisputably fast mana. These cards are the
most distinguishing feature of cEDH, the thing
that makes turn 1 or 2 wins even possible, and
Sol Ring fits into this category of card to a T.
With the card’s fast mana status in mind, printing
Sol Ring in a precon aimed at getting people into
the format has symbolic power, situating the card
as a casual staple that people should be playing.
The fact that it was printed in all five of
the first round of precons is all but saying
“dear casual commander players, this card goes
in your deck,” and it being a staple isn’t tied
to any sort of competitive, keeping up aspect of
things—mostly, more on that later. I gestured at
this argument when I pointed out that the first
round of precons were quite poorly constructed,
but I’ll make it explicit here—the decision
to print Sol Ring in every single precon since
2011 has likely had several different reasons
behind it, and even if there was a primary one
it wouldn’t be this sort of “keeping up” idea.
Commander isn’t a competitive format, there’s
nothing that inherently requires “keeping up”
with. Rather, the scarce evidence that does exist
suggests that Sol Ring was reprinted to
amplify its position as a symbol of the format,
to turn it into a mascot of sorts
that would be run far and wide and
be a point of connectivity between basically
all players. Even though I dislike the card,
I can’t deny there’s a certain power in that,
a power that was recognized by Wizards of the
Coast in 2010. I also alluded to the monetary
motivation in The Problem with Budget Cards,
and this is almost certainly another one of the
factors involved in printing Sol Ring. Putting
a piece of fast mana in every precon absolutely
helped Wizards of the Coast sell more units—they
were a business putting out a new product line
and they wanted to make sure it was successful. I
was a bit smarmy about this a year ago, because
it’s very fun to be smarmy in YouTube videos,
but the monetary element is kind of just
a fact of life in the world we live in.
Speaking of which, let’s talk about the price
argument. Heavily printing Sol Ring in commander
sets has undoubtedly kept the price of the card
low, and the price of a card being low leads more
players to play it in casual EDH. A fast mana
card being $100 or $200 rather than $1 or $2
will absolutely result in fewer people playing
that card. 85% of decks run Sol Ring, but only
11% of players run the very similar Mana Crypt,
and every commander with a more than 50% play rate
of Mana Crypt is almost exclusively used in cEDH.
So, if my goal is less fast mana in casual EDH,
and that is my general preference, not reprinting
Sol Ring absolutely would have accomplished that
goal to a large extent. Now, this is allowed
to make you uncomfortable, and it makes me
uncomfortable too, so let’s just take a minute
to sit in our discomfort with playing a card
game that is also a network of commercialized
products. The whole thing feels kinda weird,
huh? Okay, getting back into the topic at
hand, I would posit that the argument I just
presented is more or less just a mixture of my
preferences and a set of readily available facts
about the nature of humans, money, and markets.
However, on a vibes level I understand why this
was a volcanically controversial take and
in retrospect I probably wouldn’t choose to
make it again. A direct implication of what I’m
saying here is that I think it’s good when cards
I dislike are more expensive to keep them in fewer
people’s reach, and there’s something kinda harsh
about that, right? There is an undeniable element
of inherent classism to players with more money
having access to more cards than less wealthy
opponents. This is most obvious when thinking
about high-powered staples—as somebody who plays
mostly budget decks, you can believe that I’ve
experienced some fleeting pangs of frustration
when my tuned budget piles have gotten blown
out by an opponent playing a series of powerful
staples that I’m unable to keep up with. However,
if I may be allowed this one indulgence, I
want to give just a bit of pushback here.
The classism argument is a lot weaker when it
comes to EDH compared to basically every other
constructed format in the game. cEDH is very
proxy-friendly, and for the rest of the EDH
format—the casual EDH format—there is no set
power level to keep up with. Lacking access to
a particular powerful card, while potentially
being a subjective issue within the context of
a playgroup or table, doesn’t objectively make a
deck more or less ideal in any sense. Now, this
isn’t to say power level is irrelevant—players
might have a specific power level they want to
play at, and if they’re struggling to boost a
deck up to that point a natural reaction might
be to forlornly gaze upon the Rhystic Studies and
the Great Henges and the One Rings of the world
and ask why they must be denied these things
on account of their wallet. But the solution
of all players living in a land of ubiquitous
staples, with 25% of a deck immediately gobbled
up by these sorts of high-powered cards as
soon as a player picks their colors—well,
it’s garbage. There’s a profound uncreativity to
the proliferation of so-called must-play staples
within the commander format, and when I hear
players pine after this vision of the format
my more callous instincts want to interpret this
as them saying “why can’t I be allowed to be less
creative?” I certainly don’t want to discount
the feelings of players who are struggling to
win games and not having fun because of
it—those people exist and they matter—but
in a casual social format I can come up with
several far better solutions to this problem
than just printing enough copies of The One
Ring that everybody and their uncle can have
one for 50 cents. If you want to play at a higher
power level, have a conversation about proxying!
If you want to play at a lower power level,
talk to your opponents about that! And if the
people you find yourself playing against are too
ornery and inconsiderate to spend even an ounce
of effort helping you have fun in a casual card
game format, they’re not worth playing against.
[pause]
I suppose this video wouldn’t be complete if
I didn’t return to the actual question of “The
Problem with Budget Cards”—is there a problem with
budget cards? Is it bad when a card’s price in
Dollars or Euros or Yen doesn’t reflect its power
level? Well, I think this is a question with a lot
of layers to it, and my feelings were complicated
even a year ago—despite the title/thumbnail combo,
the actual contents of the video were more of a
free-form ramble on the subject of cards like this
rather than being some sort of pointed takedown.
Sol Ring in particular serves as the most dramatic
example of a power/cost imbalance, and the fact
that one of the most powerful mana artifacts in
the game is run in all sorts of decks in the
range of janky and budget is a striking thing
to observe. This out-of-placeness is what I was
really trying to comment on—what does it mean
when a Sol Ring sits in a deck alongside
a bunch of janky commons? To some people,
this situation constitutes a problem, but to
others the answer is a dynamic game. Sol Ring can
be a factor that adds variance through its power
level and enables the common jank of the world to
keep up with the sweaty, optimized piles of the
oligarchs of the Magic: the Gathering community,
some might say. To put it in more mathematical
terms, an injection of variance will always
serve as an equalizing factoring within games.
This is true in terms of skill—a new player to
monopoly will have a better chance against average
opponents than will a new player to chess—and we
can see a parallel to this in the fact that it’s
equally likely for any player at a table to draw a
Sol Ring. We can also think about how Sol Ring
affects the average power level of a deck—if
we construct a ten point power scale and put Sol
Ring at a 10 out of 10, a deck whose average power
level is a 4 out of 10 will be more improved by
a Sol Ring than a deck whose power level is an
8 out of 10. Thus, you could argue that Sol
Ring and cards that are similarly accessible
and powerful serve as a moderating factor
between different decks and power levels.
I don’t find this argument particularly compelling
as a justification for Sol Ring itself, such is my
distaste for fast mana, but the broader point is
a reasonable one that speaks to the complexity
of a casual card game format. In addition,
there will always be cards that are powerful
compared to their price—cards see varying numbers
of copies printed, and there are a myriad of other
factors that can also serve to pump up or depress
a given card’s price. So, with all that in mind,
the answer to the question “Is there a
problem with budget cards?” is that no,
there is absolutely no inherent problem
with powerful cards being cheap. Rather,
prices of cards have an influence on
power level variance, and within the
context of a social format like EDH, the
cards being varying power levels poses certain
challenges to players. Power level differences
in cards are more easily detectable in simpler,
more mundane cards than they are for flashy
synergy picks, and players should be careful to
make sure that they end up with the right balance
of vegetables to other stuff. If your deck has a
mixture of stronger and weaker cards, this will
naturally increase its variance, and in some cases
that added variance might make opponents wary. If
they’ve seen your deck’s pop off scenario before,
they might focus attention on you even if
there’s another deck at the table that’s
more powerful overall but lower variance. These
are all challenges posed by cards having variable
power levels, and navigating them can help players
to have more fun. The framing device of budget
cards was the one I chose to string together the
specific set of points I wanted to make a year
ago, but the questions at the heart of the video
run much deeper than money. Casual formats in any
sort of game will always have an inherent tension
between more competitive play and play that is
more expressive and less goal oriented. These
things exist on a hazy spectrum, and there’s no
one place on that spectrum that will maximize fun
for all people involved in a given game or format,
no single right answer to questions about how
decks should or shouldn’t be put together. At
the end of the day, I’m just one guy giving you my
best advice on how to navigate that complex world.
Thanks for making it to the end! This was
a bit different than most of what I make,
and you can let me know what you thought
about it, because I’m genuinely curious if
this retreading of a controversial topic worked
any better for people. If you want to support me
in making videos like this, you can subscribe to
my Patreon for $3 a month. I’m currently taking
submissions for my August deck review there if
that is of any interest to you, and I’ve also
started releasing less-scripted bonus videos there
as well, including one about cascade a week ago.